[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اتهم رئيس الوزراء العراقي نوري
المالكي كلا من السعوديه وقطر باعلان
الحرب على بلاده من خلال دعم من وصفهم
بزعماء الارهاب سياسيا واعلاميا نقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين مدى وجاهه المبررات التي ساقها
المالكي لاتهام السعوديه
وقطر ودلالات توقيت اطلاق هذه الاتهامات
في ظل الازمات الحاليه في
العراق هجوم حاد شنه رئيس الحكومه
العراقيه على كل من السعوديه وقطر محملا
الدولتين مسؤوليه تدهور الوضع الامني في
بلاد
قد تختلف التحليلات بشان الاسباب التي دعت
الملك لاستهداف البلدين بتصريحاته غير ان
المؤكد هو ان العراق يعيش في ظل مجموعه من
الازمات الداخليه قبيل موعد الانتخابات
البرلمانيه مما يطرح مجموعه من الاسئله عن
توقيت ومغزى تصريحات المالك
هذه مشاهد من موجه العنف الاحدث في العراق
منذ شهور تتصاعد الهجمات بشكل مضطرد هنا
لتكشف كل يوم اكثر عن اخفاقات حكومه نور
المالكي في التعامل مع الملف الامني
معضلات امنيه تترافق ومتاعب سياسيه وازمه
طائفيه لا تزال تغذي احتجاجات مناوئه
للمالك يتحدث نور المالكي عما يسميها ازمه
العراق الطائفيه والارهابيه والامنيه اما
المسؤول عنها فيراه خارج حدود العراق ففي
مقابله مع محطه تلفزيون فرنسي
قال المالكي ان السعوديه وقطر تشن حربا
بخلفيه سياسيه وطائفه على بلاده عبر سوريا
كما اتهمهما بالعمل على زعزعه استقرار
العراق بتقديمه الدعم السياسيه والماليه
والاعلامي لجماعات مسلحه وينكر المالك ان
يكون السنه في العراق مهمشين فذاك برايه
ما يردده من يدعوهم طائفيين من السنه
تدعمهم الرياض
والدوحه انه اقوى تصريحات نور المالكي منذ
اندلاع الاضطرابات في محافظه الانبار
بغربي العراق في وقت سابق من هذا العام
لكن قوات الامن العراقيه تزعم انها تقاتل
هناك جماعات مرتبطه بتنظيم القاعده انها
بعض من المجموعات التي يتهم المالكي كلا
من قطر والسعوديه بدعمها والتي يقول انها
تنشط حاليا على جانبي الحدود العراقيه
السوريه بجوار الانبار لم ترد الدولتان
بعد على الاتهام وهما التتان تتسم
علاقاتهما مع المالك تقليديا بالفتور اذ
تريانه قريبا من ايران اكثر من اللازم فهل
يكفي ذلك مسوغا لتعمل على ضرب وحده العراق
واستقراره وهل يستقيم هذا المنطق مثلا مع
السعوديه التي ادرجت لتوها جماعات وحركات
اسلاميه على لائحه الارهاب كما توعدت من
يشارك في اعمال قتاليه خارج المملكه
بالسجن يرى محللون خليجيون ان المالكي
انما وجد شماعه يعلق عليها اخفاقات حكومته
وللرجل ربما حسابات داخليه ايضا فلعله
يحاول تحسين صورته لدى شريحه من العراقيين
قبيل انتخابات مقرره في نهايه ابريل
المقبل معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستديو عبد الله بن حمد العذبه مدير
تحرير صحيفه العرب القطريه من بغداد مصطفى
حبيب عضو ائتلاف دوله القانون ومعنا ايضا
من جده عبر الهاتف الدكتور انور ماجد عشقي
المحلل والسياسي والخبير الاستراتيجي
السعودي اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا نبدا من بغداد
سيد مصطفى حبيب هذا الاتهام المالكي
للسعوديه
وقطر هو الاعنف
والاوض على ماذا
استند شكرا لا استضافتكم لنا في هذا
البرنامج الحواري واشكرك استاذ محمد على
هذا السؤال ايضا حقيقه الامر ان باعتقادي
ان السيد نوري المالكي لم يكشف جديدا ولم
يكشف شيئا مستورا انما العمليات الجاريه
في الدوله المجاوره سوريا وانتقلت الى
الانبار وانتقلت عن عبر الحدود الى بعض
مناطق شمال العراق في الموصل ليست قضايا
يعني ليس هنك اناس جاؤوا مدججين بالسلاح
ومهيئين للقتال بنفس الطريقه التي يقاتلون
فيها في سوريا جاؤوا من حدود اخرى انما
هذه الحدود المشتركه الطويله كشفت من خلال
الممارسات داخل سوريا في بعض بعض بؤها
تضرب ف تاتي وتعبر الحدود والحدود طبيعه
الحال قد يكون ان هنالك لابد من وجود حرس
حدود لكن بهذا الامتداد لا يمكن ضبط
الحدود بطريقه حديديه بحيث لا يمكن تسلل
اي عنصر من العناصر بالاضافه الى ان
الامتداد الموجود داخل العراق لهذه
الجماعات من اعضاء تنظيم القاعده ومن من
تسلل من من داعش اللي هي دوله العراق
الاسلاميه في الشام و والعراق هذه كلها
دلائل ليست ظنيه وانما ت تعطي الدليل
الكبير جدا على ان هذه الامتدادات
لمساعدات ودعمها ليس من داخل العراق داخل
العراق لا يملك هذه الامكانيات حتى
المعارضين لحكومه السيد المالكي ولكن سيد
حبيب يعني القطه فقط بسرعه على افتراض ان
السعوديه وقطر تدعم هذه الحركات فعلا ا
قولا واعلا ومالا وسلاحا داخل سوريا هل
معنى ذلك انها اذا انتقلت الى العراق
انتقلت بقرار سعودي وقطري
ايضا لا لا سبق ان قدمت حضرتك ان العلاقه
تتسم بفتور يعني طبيعي منذ سنوات لان
حقيقه الامر لا يخفى على احد ان ال الدول
التي كان لها انا بتصوري هنالك قوى معارضه
لنظام صدام السابق اللي سقط قبل 11 سنه
هي تملك مواقف مضاده لها من قبل بعض من
قبل كثير من العرب وممن حتى ولج في بيوتهم
في الكويت سنه 1990 ووصل الى حدود المملكه
السعوديه ودخل بعض اراضيها برغم كل هذا
فان الموقف الواضح المسدد المساند
للمعارضه العراقيه لم يكن بتلك الجداره
التي يمكن ان يعني نتوقعها من اشقاء عرب
وهم متضر وهذا الاتهام من السيد المالكي
نعم بعد اذنك الاتهام السيد المالكي وصل
الى حد الاتهام بان الد الدولتين اعلنت
الحرب هنا نسال ضيفنا من السعوديه الدكتور
انور ماجد عشقي هل ترى هذه الاتهامات في
محلها
اولا بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله وعلى اله
واصحابه ومنوه ان من يقرا الموقف في
العراق يجد بان هذه الاتهامات ليست في
محله خصوصا وان الحدود العراقيه مع
السعوديه هي وقطر جنوبيه قطر الحقيقه ما
في حدود مع العراق السعوديه الحدود جنوبيه
و فكيف تكون هذه الحدود
شماليه السيد المالكي دائما يتهم الاخرين
بمشاكله هو فمثلا في البدايه يتهم فيما
مضى سوريا بانها هي تصد الارهاب وهدد بانه
سينقل الارهاب اليهم واليوم لا يستطيع ان
يهدد سوريا ولا يستطيع ان يهدد غير
المملكه العربيه السعوديه فهدد المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وقطر فطبعا واتهم
المملكه السعوديه وقطر فاذا معناها ان
السيد المالكي الان في ظرف صعب جدا اولا
ال جماعته في الداخل انتقدوا عليه بعضهم
انتقدوا عليه ثانيا في الخارج طبعا في
الداخل ايضا الارهاب وطبعا اول كانت عباره
عن مطالبه في الشمال بالمساواه والعداله
وايضا اطلاق السج المساجين والسجينات كل
هذه واليوم طبعا وجد انه كمان حتى السيد
مقتضى الصدر اعترض عليه
وقال كلاما يعني يعني كلاما دقيقا تجاه
المالكي واتهمه بالدكتاتور واتهمه بعدم
القدره على اداره الحكم كل هذه الامور
جعلت المالكي يريد ان يرحل المشاكل
الداخليه الىى الخارج ولكنه ولكنه مع ذلك
دكتور اسمح لي مع ذلك كان يعني واضحا
وضوحا شديدا في في هذه الاتهامات في
مقابلته مع قناه فرنسا
24 سيد العذبه السيد الملكي يقول ازمه
العراق الطائفيه والارهابيه والامنيه يعني
بهذا البعد الثلاثي هي مسؤوليه السعوديه
وقطر استمعنا الى وجهه نظر السعوديه ماذا
عن قطر اولا اشكركم على الاستضافه واثني
على كلام الدكتور عشقي بالفعل اتهم
المالكي السيد المالكي بشار الاسد او نظام
الاسد بانه كان يقف خلف العمليات
الارهابيه
داخل العراق والان وجه سهامه
باتجاه قطر
والسعوديه بال يعني الا يمكن ان يكون عفوا
الا يمكن ان يكون محق في ذلك الوقت ربما
بشار الاسد الذي كان يدعم الان ربما
السعوديه وقطر دعني اكمل اذا سمحت لي
بالنسبه لزميلنا من العراق طبعا هو حاول
ان يتلاعب بالاسم داعش اتت من الدوله
الاسلاميه في العراق والشام حرف العين قبل
حرف الشين فهي انطلقت اصلا من العراق
وانتقلت الى سوريا
فعمل الهجوم التي يتحدثون عنها بالنسبه
لداعش انطلقت من العراق ولم تاتي من الشام
وهم الان يتحدثون بان العمليات العمليات
التي يتعرضون لها اتت من الشام وهذا امر
محض افتراء بالاضافه الى انني اعتقد يعني
انا كمحلل اعتقد بان العراق يحتاج اليوم
الى رئيس توافقي لا يحمل نفسا طائفيا
وتكون ا اجندته هي ان يكون هناك عراق
بعيدا عن الطرح الطائفي عراق يقبل بالجميع
اكراد وسنه وشيعه ولكن حتى نبقى في هذه
الاتهامات اسمح لي سيد العذبه يعني نبحث
عن ادله يقدم لنا ادله اذا كان لديه
بالضبط اذا اذا في في هذه الحاله الا يمكن
اعتبار بان الوضع السوري فاض على الوضع
العراقي يعني ليس بالضروره السعوديه
والدوحه تقصد الاساءه للعراق ربما بسبب
الوضع السوري وهو اشار الى هذه النقطه هل
هل يمكن ان يكون الوضع السوري اساء العراق
من حيث لم تكن السعوديه وقطر تقصد
بالضروره العراق دعني اؤكد على نقطه مهمه
اولا من فتح السجون واطلق رجال داعش
ليذهبوا الى الشام لسنوات طويله هم
موجودين في السجون العراقيه فمن اطلق
سراحهم فجاه ليرسل الى الشام لا قطر قامت
بذلك ولا المملكه العربيه السعوديه قامت
بذلك وان حاول البعض اشغالها بصراع جانبي
مع دوله قطر او مع بعض التوجهات هنا
لابعادها عن الخطر الحقيقي والذي
تمثله المساله العراقيه والتوجهات التي
يمثلها نوري المالكي هناك يعني هذا
التصريح ليس بمستغرب من خلال رصدنا لشهور
طويله منذ ان قامت الثوره السوريه هناك
هجوم ممنهج ضد كل من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه شقيقه قطر الكبيره وقطر لان
الدولتين لهما يعني موقف واضح من دعم
الثوره السوريه بغض النظر عن توجهات
الفصائل التي يدعمونها ففي المحصله الكل
يبحث عن مساعده الشعب السوري بطريقته وان
شاء الله يعني يكون هناك دائما تنسيق واضح
في سوريا سيد حبيب في بغداد سواء ضيفنا في
في الرياض او هنا في الاستديو اشار الى
موضوع الادله هل فعلا السيد المالكي يملك
من الادله ما يجعل هذا الاتهام يقف على
رجليه السؤال هو ان القوى المعارضه التي
تقاتل والتي تفجر هنا وهناك وكان اخر
تفجير في الحله اليوم وذهب ضحيته اكثر من
45 شهيدا هذا العمل حقيقه لا تملك اي قوه
داخل العراق ان تساند وان
وان تصرف من المال على على عناصره صغارا
وكبارا
وهذا حقيقه يعني ما ما اعتقد بحاجه الى دل
نص الى نص بكلام او او نص تصريح من جهه
سعوديه او جهه قطريه تقول ذلك انما
المواقف السياسيه هي الت التي تقف وراء
هذا الدعم
وا اسحلي سيد حب اسمحلي اسمحلي سيد حبيب
الاخ ذكر ان د اسمي داعش انطلقت من العراق
اسمحلي بالداخله ل هذه هنا في هذه الحاله
هناك فرق ب هناك فرق بين ان تقول السعوديه
وقطر تؤيدان او او هواهم السياسي مع هذه
المعارضه وبين ان تتهمها بانها تشن حربا
وبان العنف والطائفيه والارهاب كله من
السعوديه
وقطر اخويا مصالح البلدان المجاوره بعض
البلدان المجاوره ومنها قطر والسعوديه
بسبب بسبب تغير النظام في داخل العراق
والنظام داخل العراق حتى لو كان هذا يتكلم
على المالكي وذاك يسب وهذا يشتم النظام
ديمقراطي الحريه المتوفره لابناء الشعب
العراقي في التعبير عن رايها من الحاكم او
من الوزير او من المسؤول ليست موجوده في
اي دوله من هذه الدول اتحدى اي دوله من
هذه الدول التي تسن قانونا لمن يتهجم على
الامير او على الملك او على كذا بالسجن او
بالاعدام او بغير ذلك هذا الامر جدا طبيعي
ان ان ياتي الاخ بدليل على ان داخل العراق
عنده جبهه الناس كلها تعارضه وهذا هذا
يتكلم عليه وهذا ينتقد هذا كل شيء طبيعي
جدا منذ عشر منذ 11 سنه في العراق لم يكن
كذا وضع مرشحا لان ياتي في اي بلد اخر من
المفارقه هذه المره سيد حبيب وهنا اسال
ضيفنا من جده وليس من الرياض الدكتور
عشقي المفارقه ان الكل كان يتحدث وليس سرا
بان السعوديه وقطر تدعم المعارضه السوريه
هذه لاول مره يتم جمع السعوديه وقطر
للحديث بشكل علني وصريح انهما يدعمان
ويؤديان الارهاب الذي يجري في العراق كما
يقول
المالكي سيد عشقي اي افضل اف افضل اذا كان
الكلام ل نعم افضل انا اول مره اعتب على
ما تفضل به الاستاذ مصطفى نعم تفضل الاخ
مصطفى طبعا في البدايه خلط بين القرائن
والبينات فهو الان يقول عن قرائن انه
طالما ان هناك لا يمكن هنا قوه يكون لها
كذا كذا هذه كلها قرائن ما فيش بينه
معناها انه ال السيد المالكي ليس لديه
بينه فيما يقول انما هي اتهامات
جزافيه يلقيها يبحث عن من يلقيها عليه
القاها على المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اسقطت في يده عمليه الارهاب
واتهامها بالارهاب حينما شجبت الارهاب
وحينما جرمت عمليه الارهاب وحينما منعت
ابنائها من خروج الخارج وجرم من يحارب
الارهاب في الخارج او في الداخل فهو يريد
طبعا يريد ان طبعا يعني يسقط هذا العمل
الذي او يشكك في هذا العمل الذي قامت به
المملكه بالنسبه ل الشقيقه قطر شاف انه
قطر لابد انها تساعد الشعب السوري لحمايته
من البراميل والقتل فال قطر والسعوديه
يساعدان الشعب السوري في من ذلك فهو
وضعهما في معسكر واحد وانهما يتهمان لو
كانت السعوديه تريد ان تعمل شيئا لكانت
السعوديه دعمت الاكراد على الاقل
بالانفصال لو كان السعوديه تعمل ذلك كان
عملت امر اخر لكن السعوديه وقطر لا تتامر
على الدول ولا تساعدان الارهاب ولكنهما
يقفان بجوار الشعوب فاذا لان ذلك ادعى
لتحقيق الامن القومي العربي والامن القومي
الاسلامي نعم اشر اشرت الى نقطه مهمه جدا
دكتور عشقي وهي مساله القرائن والبينات
سيد العذبه هل تعتقد فعلا ان هناك اشكال
في موضوع القرائن والبيانات في الاتهام
العراقي اولا طبعا نحن لا نتحدث عن النظام
العراقي كنظام نحن نتحدث عن ممارسات السيد
المالكي تجاه السعوديه وتجاه قطر وهناك
عمليه ممنهجه
لشيطنة لهاتين الدولتين ومحاوله لوصه ما
بالارهاب من خلال ماكينه اعلام تقوم يعني
الجهات عراقيه خلفها محاوله في محاوله
لشيطنة
زميلنا من العراق ان يتهم مقتدى الصدر بان
طرحه طائفي باي شكل من الاشكال فالمشكله
هي الان تتحدث عن ان نوري المالكي لديه
مشكله مع جميع الاطياف داخل العراق ويريد
تصدير الازمه الى كل من ق وهذه النقطه
وهذه النقطه تحديدا التي نريد ان نتوقف
عندها بعد الفاصل نريد ان نعرف دلالات
توقيت اطلاق هذه الاتهامات من قبل السيد
المالكي في ظل الازمات الحاليه التي يمر
بها في العراق لنا عوده بعد فاصل قصير
نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها اتهامات رئيس
الوزراء العراقي نور المالكي لكل من
السعوديه وقطر بشن حرب على بلاده ودعم
الارهاب هناك سيد مصطفى حبيب في في ثنايا
كل من كلام ضيفنا في الاستديو وضيفنا من
جده الاشاره الى ان السيد نوري المالكي
مشكلته داخليه ويبحث عن شماعات يعلق عليها
هذه المشاكل ما تعليقك على مثل هذا
الاتهام اقول عودا على بدء اذا كان
للمالكي اذا كان المالكي لا يملك اي دليل
فمن حق اي متهم ان يسال عن الدليل
وبالتالي فهنالك دول تتكلم مع بعض هنالك
سلطات تتحادث مع بعض ممكن ومن حق المملكه
السعوديه من حق دوله قطر ان ان تطالب
السيد المالكي بهذه بادله وليس من خلال ما
نتحدث في الاعلام ولكن القاعده تقول البين
البينه على من ادعى القاعده تقول البينه
على من ادعى عندما يتهم يجب ان يطرح
الادله حتى يكون مفما صحح نعم نعم نعم نعم
قد لا يكن من المصلحه ان تطرح الادله علنا
في نفس التصريح قد تكون لديه ادله يمكن ان
يطرحها فيما بعد لان المسائل لا يمكن ان
تطرح دفعه واحده بهذه الطريقه قد يكون
لديه والمقابله الصحفيه لا تتحمل ان يذكر
الادله التفصيليه التي ليس من شان يعني
الصحيفه ان تعرفها او من شان اذا ننتظر
ادله في اليومين المقبلين اذا ننتظر ادله
في اليومين المقبلين بشكل واضح لا لا يسال
عن الادله لا يسال عن الادله لا واذا لم
يسال الانسان يتهم اتهام كبير بهذا الشكل
ثم يمضي في حال سبيله و هات هاتي البينه
لا هو يقدم البينه ق هات هاتوا ها لا هو
هو اتهم فعليه ان
يبين يعني ليس من من دور قطر او السعوديه
ان تطالب بال بالبينات هو هو اتهم فعليه
ان يوضح لا لا
قطر قطر والسعوديه من حقها ويجب عليها
وطنيا ان ترد على هذه الاتهامات وتطالب
بالدليل ليس كذلك لا ليس كذلك لا ليس كذلك
يعني عندما عندما يتهم سيد نوري المالكي
عندما يتهم سيد نوري المالكي دولت بشن حرب
على بلاده يقول واحد اثين ثلاث اعه فعلى
الاقل يعطي دليل اثنين ان لا يمكن ان يطلق
اتهام ثم يم في حال سبيله نعم على كل ليس
هذا الموضوع تفضل بالاضافه الى هذا
بالاضافه الى هذا نحن نملك نحن نملك من
خلال الاعلام ومن خلال الاعترافات للذين
تم اعتقالهم من الارهابيين ان انهم
يتزودون وجاؤوا من بلدان معينه ومنها
السعوديه ومنها دول اخرى ولكن حينما منعت
او قضت المملكه السعوديه في في الشهر
الماضي بان الذي بمنع مشاركه السعوديين
المواطنين السعوديين لم يمنعها هذا من
تجنيد مواطنين من دول اخرى خ المساله
الداخليه مساله مهمه جدا سيد عشقي تراها
هي المحدده في هذا الاتهام للسيد
المالكي لا شك
طبعا السيد المالكي الان اقتربت الساعه
بالنسبه له اللي ساعه الانتخابات
طبعا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه متضجر من
تصرفاته طبعا وهذا ما بدا حينما ذهب
والتقى بالرئيس اوباما الرئيس اوباما طلب
منه ان يحقق العداله والاستقرار في العراق
ولكنه فشل في
ذلك السيد المالكي طبعا دائما يعني نجده
دائما يحكم يعني القضيه الامنيه وليس
القضيه العقليه في حل المشاكل
فالقضايا طبعا الوسائل الامنيه هذه طبعا
تؤجج النار وخاصه في هذا العصر بالذات
يعني الان ما لم يعد هناك ستالين ولم يعد
هناك هتلر ولم يعد كذا اذا معناها انه
لابد السيد المالكي يفتح باب الحوار
الصحيح وايضا يحقق العداله لان اي بلد
فيها عداله اجتماعيه ووحده وطنيه لا يمكن
ان تضام ولا يكون فيها ارهاب ولا تكون
فيها مشاكل نعم سيد العذبه تعتبر ان هذ
يعني بعد اذنك سيد الذبه تعتبر ان هذا هو
بيت القصيده الان في الوضع العراق الداخلي
طبعا من المعلوم ان نائب الرئيس الامريكي
اعلن عن دعم امريكا لتوجهات المالكي
لمحاربه الارهاب ولكن عندما فشل نوري
المالكي في قمع الناس بناء على على امر
طائفي في الانبار توجه كان يعني هناك
شماعه جاهزه دعني اهاجم كل من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وقطر
مستغلا الصوره النمطيه بانهما دولتين يعني
سلفيت او وهابيت كما يحلو للبعض ان يسميه
ما فكان من الاسهل ان يعلق الفشل الذي
حققه سياسيا وتصدير المشاكل الداخليه التي
يعاني منها مع كل الاطياف داخل العراق بما
فيهم مقتدى الصدر وتعليقها على شماعه كل
من السعوديه وقطر شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الله
بن حمد العذبه مدير تحرير صحيفه العرب
القطريه شكرا ايضا لضيف
من جده عبر الهاتف الدكتور انور ماجد عشقي
المحلل السياسي والخبير الاستراتيجي
السعودي وضيفنا من بغداد مصطفى حبيب عضو
ائتلاف دوله القانون في امان
[موسيقى]
الله
ه